a few weeks ago I created a video called
zoom the Skype versus WebEx and you guys
really enjoyed it so today I wanted to
take a little bit further in a belly
weight Skype versus Microsoft teams
what's going on guys my name is David
homage from welcome back to the channel
today we're going to be comparing the
base level of Skype against Microsoft
teams well let's take a look at both of
these platforms and understand who might
be using Skype and who might be using
Microsoft teams starting off with Skype
and one of the biggest and most
interesting factors that I've come
across lately is the fact that on their
website now they claim end-to-end
encryption in very big bold letters
considering all the controversy around
zoom lately and the fact that they
previously claimed and to end encryption
but didn't actually have antenna
encryption is very interesting and then
when you take a look at Microsoft team's
website know where today state and any
encryption Microsoft teams of states at
rest and in transit encryption so
there's still potential there for some
encryption errors but they don't go on
make that bold intend claim Skype
provides you with these interesting chat
features and voice and video call
options just like Microsoft teams does
it allows you to transfer files and
store files on skype the same way
Microsoft teams does it allows you to
call other people directly and schedule
calls in the future as well the
scheduling feature on stripe isn't the
greatest I've been honest and Microsoft
teams definitely does a much better job
and scheduling calls and planning out
your organizer so if this is something
is very important to you probably only
to watch the rest of this video you can
just jump to Microsoft teams right now
subscribers have some interesting
features which Microsoft teams has as
well but it comes down to a pricing
point of view if you're looking to
purchase an international phone number
or call international mobile numbers
directly there is a purpose for that
definite
you can call most countries around the
world and set up an original phone
number in that country to actually start
using Skype as a mobile device as an
external number so I guess for people
who don't have the access to the
Internet for example grandparents in a
foreign country maybe they can only call
via the telephone this might be a very
helpful feature especially considering
how much telcos charge for international
calls both Skype and Microsoft teams
have HD video calls for video
conferencing needs if you need to share
files quickly in between participants
they're both very good at this where
Microsoft teams steps up the game a
little bit is the fact it's integrated
with office 365
very very well so you can intuitively
start editing different word documents
editing different Excel spreadsheets
directly in teams versus having to send
files and rename them send them back and
have a million-in-one copies the best
thing about these platforms is you can
now share a link and invite anybody to a
videoconference at any given time so
previously you would have had to sign up
to Skype to actually be able to join and
get a call whereas now you can simply
share like let them join and begin
talking straight away again with
Microsoft team steps up here is it's
integrated with your office 365 calendar
so you can easily schedule that call put
it in your calendar you get a
notification when the time comes and you
can just click on the link and start
your videoconference Microsoft teams
also has an array of different built-in
features for example we have a to-do
list dedicated into the app and also a
new feature called walkie-talkie coming
very soon so you can start using your
mobile phone as a walkie-talkie device
and remove another cost from your
business so basically what Microsoft
teams is trying to here and I think
they've actually done it reasonably well
is producer software to collaborate with
in-house and out of house so for those
who are stuck in isolation right now and
struggling to communicate with the rest
of their team who's potentially anywhere
around the world
Microsoft team is definitely a great
option to get you started it is one of
the place
there you can do a whole bunch of
different features if you're ready on
the 365 platform it doesn't cost you
absolutely anything to use most of their
features and if you're a company that's
looking to train people during this
quarantine period and you don't know how
to train them once they're at home you
can easily start storing information in
Microsoft teams so for example you can
implement all your policies or your
training videos or your guidelines for
new staff or existing staff to read and
brush up on in times like this another
reason Microsoft teams takes over the
crown from Skype is the simple fact that
the scribe is very prominent in the
mobile phone a-calling sector of the
market whereas now Microsoft teams
actually has implemented its very own
desktop phone systems to have a business
with a hundred calls coming in a day
multiple consultants and everybody needs
to be on the same line but you don't
want to pay the ridiculous fees that are
associated with these sorts of business
setups then Microsoft teams actually
allows you to do that from within this
one built app it's definitely a cool
feature that is more targeted at the
larger corporations or even the small to
medium businesses just starting to
expand into this market and really want
to use new technology to their advantage
with the added benefit of having up to
10,000 people on any teams call is
definitely a much superior platform than
Skype it takes all the features that
Skype does really well doesn't better
and it integrates a million-one
other software features as well so for
me it's a very simple go to Microsoft
teams if you haven't used any of these
platforms before if you're on skype it's
worth considering the switch anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you're
enjoying the additional content during
this quarantine period usually it's one
video a week every Monday now it's three
times a week Monday Wednesday Friday
today Wednesday I will see you on Friday